Loki and the TVA are back to tackle more
time-bending cases on Disney plus if the
trailer for the second season is any
indication there'll be plenty of
mysteries to solve and foes to face this
time around with the god of Mischief the
trailer opens with an extended sequence
of focuses on an interaction between
Mobius Loki and an entirely new
character played by Ki Hui Kwan an
officially identified as auroboros
Mobius just calls him OB there's a lot
going on here the Messi antique shop of
an office that the scene takes place in
and the fact that Loki glitches out of
existence as if he's auditioning for a
cameo in Sony's spider-verse franchise
but the star of this cold open is
unquestionably Hui Kwan Hui Kwan's
character seems to function as a help
desk can you fix that no Daniel rigdemon
who leads the apparent name of Pui
Kwan's character name back in 2022
referred to Aura boros as a queue of the
TVA likely referring to the gadget man
from the James Bond franchise rather
than the reality warping figure from
Star Trek but you never know in 2022 Hui
one starred in everything everywhere all
at once the Multiverse spanning best
picture Oscar winner if that film is any
indication of who he Quan's role in the
MCU it's no wonder the trailer is
teasing his potential here we expected
plenty of mind-bending things to appear
in Loki season 2. but an MCU character
working at a fast food restaurant is a
particular surprise Sylvie a key Loki
variant from the first season appears at
one point in the trailer in a vintage
McDonald's uniform that said there may
be more to the mcu's version of the
golden arches and meets the eye judging
by Sylvie's worried look things aren't
going according to plan for her look
closely and you can spot five missed
minutes clocks clipped into Sylvie's
name tag like a five-star rating this
visual clue could hint at how silby
found herself in this situation Miss
minutes answers to he who remains the
Kang variant who ultimately reshaped the
TVA into His Image so is this McDonald's
a prison for Sylvie or is she hiding in
plain sight somehow McDonald's even
replied to Marvel's trailer on Twitter
specifically mentioning Miss minutes so
there's definitely something significant
going on here in a scene it's a movie
theater the film title zaniac can be
seen on the Marquee zaniac debuted in
1982's Thor issue 319 in which movie
star Brad wolf portrays a blood craving
creature who wears a costume that makes
him appear monstrous an accidental
explosion transforms him into the host
for a mystical entity zaniac would later
take on other hosts after leaving Wolf's
body the comics later revealed that
zaniac jumps through different hoes for
centuries the official Handbook of the
Marvel Universe even claims he was
responsible for the Jack the Ripper
killings that leads to another
interesting Connection in 1990s Dr
Strange source for a supreme issue 23
this revealed Jack the Ripper was under
the control of dormammu the ruler of the
dark dimension who appeared in the first
Doctor Strange movie
I've come to bargain much of the Loki
season 2 trailer centers around the
movie premiere and just tease of zaniac
from the looks of it the event will be
the focal point of at least one episode
as we see Hunter B15 Mobius and Loki
seemingly all at the event but as Rafael
casal's mysterious character who may be
the most important part Gasol's
character presumably an actor appears a
few times in the trailer in one shot
eagle-eyed viewers May spot a fan
holding a sign that reads Marry Me Brad
Wolfe the sign is pointing at casal's
character this suggests the actor Will
portray Wolff with zaniac's first host
to appear in the comics Loki confronts
the actor which seems to suggest some
TVA mischief and timeline bending is a
foot in deadlines report about Casal
joining the Loki cast the outlet said
Marvel was keeping his role Under Wraps
but the outlets also reported that
there's been online speculation that
he's tied to zaniac the time traveling
reality altering ending of the first
season of Loki left a lot of threads up
in the air can silby and Loki make their
relationship work well Mobius remember
his best friend in the Universe though
we don't know for sure quite yet we may
get an answer to one burning question
what is the deal with mobius's love of
jet skis there's nothing inherently
wrong with loving personal watercraft
but the TVA agent's fixation with it was
so specific that it has to be addressed
jet ski
that's what I like to do there's an
already run on my jet ski it looks like
fans could get the moment they've been
waiting to see as Loki continues to be
thrown through time he finds himself at
the one place Mobius would love to go
Loki lands a piranha Power Sports the
store for all your jet ski needs the god
of Mischief Landing in front of a row of
jet skis could be a wing to the audience
about the origins of mobius's passion
but one moment he's there and the next
he's gone so we only get a glimpse
either way perhaps this is where a
pre-tva Mobius worked and cultivated his
love of water scooters it's a hint That
season 2 viewers could see mobius's pass
and possibly what led to his stint of
the time variance Authority
the Loki season 2 trailer sees Loki and
morbius travel back in time to Chicago's
1893 World's Fair the heroes are there
to deal with the pressing issue of
saving the world from possible
Annihilation but we are getting some
serious circus of crime Vibes about the
whole thing in Marvel Comics a circus of
crime is a criminal organization whose
members use mind control powers to Rob
Carnival crowds they were active members
of the Nazi party who sought to
undermine Americans by killing
government officials however their plans
are always foiled by Thor Captain
America and Marvel's other Heroes the
Loki trailer doesn't appear to feature
any of their members but the carnival
setting of The World's Fair is
interesting it's certainly the type of
event where you might expect to find the
circus of crime given that there are
plenty of people to Rob and they tend to
resent displays of American extravagance
then again there's another Villain at
the Big Show who seems intent on causing
trouble for attendees toward the end of
the trailer Victor timely who was a Kang
variant appears and tells a crowd that
they have a difficult choice to make
afterward he unleashes some powerful
forces on the unsuspecting audience
which is quite reminiscent of the leader
of the circus ringmaster
The Living Tribunal is one of the most
important figures in the Marvel
Multiverse it's a cosmic entity
responsible for overseeing and
arbitrating existence second only to the
one above all the Loki season 2 trailer
has two potential references to the
three-headed figure maloki travels back
in time he walks by a house with a
number 157 on it the living tribunal's
first Cameo appearance came in Strange
Tales issue 157 later the number 158 can
be seen on a car possibly referencing
the living tribunal's First full
appearance in Strange Tales issue 158
The Living Tribunal has had three
appearances in the MCU thus far in
season 1 of Loki it's an Easter egg
scene inside the void in Doctor Strange
in the Multiverse of Madness we Glimpse
the faces of the Living Tribunal on
America Chavez and Doctor Strange tumble
through different realities in Thor love
and thunder the character's faces can be
seen in eternity's Temple as a statue
given its vast importance to maintaining
the multiverses balance in the Marvel
Universe it'd be appropriate for The
Living Tribunal to appear especially
with the recent damage to the timeline
after Sylvie killed he who remains The
Living Tribunal is showing up in Loki
would emphasize how Grand the cosmic
universe is much has changed between
Loki season 1 and 2 including a rather
large promotion for Casey in season 1
the TVA employee was just a corporate
grunt who kept several versions of the
Infinity Stones in one of his desk
drawers
of my entire lesbian it does but by the
end of the season the Disney plus series
credited actor Eugene Cordero as Hunter
k5e signaling Casey's new role in Kang's
revamped TVA now the season 2 trailer
has finally given us our first look at
him in action Casey appears briefly
walking through a dark alley with two
mysterious figures behind him from the
looks of things he seems to be in a
somewhat precarious position hinting
that the more serious tone for the
second season as usual The Marvelous
remains relatively tight-lived on
details regarding Loki season 2.
including Casey's promotion into a
hunter assuming he's still on the TVA
side he could be the hunter leading the
charge to hunt down Loki or Sylvie or
Casey could be working with a Loki
variance to bring down Kang's new regime
from the inside deadline first reported
cordero's real world promotion to a
series regular for season 2 meaning the
only thing fans know for sure is that
they can expect to see much more of
Casey when Loki returns to Disney Plus
in season 1 Miss minute serves two roles
in one master she has an AI program
designed by he who remains to function
as a face and mascot of the time
variants Authority where she preaches
its propaganda she works to spread false
cheer and keep members of the TVA
thoroughly indoctrinated at every turn
she's also the snitch who adds some
Mobius to the higher ups but miss
minutes must have scored a promotion
because none of her current job duties
include transforming into a giant
Pac-Man ghost monster in the trailer for
season 2 Marvel fans are treated to a
clip of Miss minutes growing into some
sorts of digital Kaiju with her size
comes a commensurate level of Rage to
boot but it's unclear If this means that
Miss minutes will feature more
prominently in the story of season 2.
after all the trailer intentionally
obfuscates Jonathan Major's part in The
Narrative so the depiction of Miss
minutes transformation is no guarantee
of increased screen time still it's a
cool Visual and if these power upgrades
are any indication of what's to come in
season 2 we're in for this Wild Ride
thank you